if you want to see me pretty much just  be miserable then stick around to the  end of this video look there might be a  couple that you can find but after  sitting through that thing for over two  hours and basically just being them  filming the book but it takes place in  2002 instead of 1979 I really don't feel  like it's like what do you want for me I  had to sit through the area code line  [Applause]  you want me to tell you that the Freddie  Prinze jr. movie that Tommy references  is he's all bad a movie that I only know  about it because of the rumor that my  night shyamalan ghost rodents do you  want me to tell you how they referenced  the shining with that little pig little  pig line for no other reason than the  fact that it's a Stephen King movie that  people like well too bad I don't have  the will to do this right now  I'll see you in the next one assuming we  both survive  you